how do you build that trusting team
so I'll tell you a funny story it's a
true story that really captures what it
means to be on a trusting team
I went on a business trip to Las Vegas
and they very generously put me up in
the Four Seasons
uh and the Four Seasons happens to have
a coffee bar in the lobby in in that
hotel and so one afternoon I went and
bought myself a cup of coffee
and the Barista working that day was a
kid named Noah
Noah was funny and charming and engaging
and I stood there for far too long
buying a cup of coffee because I just
enjoyed talking to Noah
so as is my nature I asked Noah do you
like your job
without skipping a beat Noah said I love
my job
now in my line of work that's
significant like is rational I like the
people I like the challenge I get paid
well I like my job love is emotional
it's a higher order connection for
example if I ask you do you love your
wife and you say I like her a lot right
I I know there's a difference
right
and Noah said I love my job in other
words he told me he's got a higher order
connection emotional connection to his
work so I immediately followed up and I
said tell me specifically
what the Four Seasons is doing
that you would even say to me I love my
job and again without skipping a beat he
said throughout the day managers will
walk past me and ask me if I'm okay ask
me if there's anything that they can do
to help me he said not just my manager
any manager
and then he said I also work at another
hotel and there the managers catch us
doing things wrong
there the managers are only concerned
about what our performance is he says
there I keep my head below the radar
just want to get through the day and
collect my paycheck he said only at the
Four Seasons do I feel I can be myself
now think about that for a second this
is the exact same human being and yet
our experience of him in one hotel with
versus the other will be profoundly
different not because of him
but because of the leadership
environment in which he works
uh the one with good leadership he'll be
amazing like I experienced and the one
with bad leadership he'll be terrible we
always think it's the people but very
often it's the leadership environment
and so we've all been we all know what
it feels like to be on a trusting team
we all have been there it's when you can
raise your hand and say I made a mistake
or I'm having trouble at home and it's
affecting my work or you've given me a
job and I don't feel trained or
qualified for it I need more training or
uh I don't know what I'm doing
um and we say these things with the
confidence that our leader or our
colleagues will rush in to support us
with no fear of humiliation or
retribution that's what it means to be
on a trusting team unfortunately we also
all know what it means not to be on a
trusting team where we would never admit
mistakes or say we don't know or say we
need help for fear that it will hurt our
ability to be promoted or it will be
humiliated by somebody in public
um or somehow jeopardize our careers and
so we keep it to ourselves
and eventually things break it's only
the organizations where we can talk
about the truth in a supported
environment that thrive over time that's
a trusting team and that's one of the
primary responsibilities of a good
leader is to build an environment in
which a trusting team can happen